[Musik]
du hast du dich schon mal daran gewöhnen
das was bei uns sind raus könnte danke
für die information
es gibt auf dieser erde seine magische
momente die manche von uns nie erleben
manche nur einmal in ihrer ganzen zeit
die sie auf dieser erde verbringen eine
schlimme krankheit hat sich auf einmal
auf wundersame art und weise von selbst
man schaut nacht aus dem fenster und
sieht ein ufo vorbeifliegen oder es gibt
eine hd tv parodie von einer sendung die
eigentlich selbst schon als itv ist ihr
kennt ihr bestimmt alle also tv von rtl
dass seine sendung bei rtl angeblich
sich das ziel gesetzt hat landwirten in
deutschland eine partnerin zu suchen und
so wie diese ganze sendung aufgebaut ist
könnte man das auf jeden fall schon zum
aasee tv zählen aber jetzt was besonders
passiert ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
wie mir der kopf steht denn es gibt auf
dem hilf mir youtube kanal eine art tv
parodie von bauer sucht frau das ganze
so nimmt ausmaße an
was soll man dagegen machen ich kann ja
nicht zwei mal aufstehen und rausgehen
kleine pizza das video von dem ich
gerade rede und das uns in den nächsten
minuten mit schwung aus den socken
scheppern wird heißt bauer sucht barbie
und wir schauen uns sofort an leute kurz
vorher noch ein kurzes schaudert und
meinen lieblings kommentar und im
letzten video der kommt von maria wird
und sie schreibt wem verschönern seine
videos auch den tag dann kann dich maria
und dank an alle die die videos schauen
und immer fleißig kommentieren oder auch
nicht kommentieren ich für euch und
jetzt lasst uns ein paar gehirnzellen
verlieren
[Musik]
okay da muss man mal ganz kurz stoppen
ganz kurz was ist das für eine szene
lasst uns mal ganz kurz auf uns wirken
während im hintergrund eine wunderschöne
landschaftliche szene windräder eine
kleiner fällt weg und auf diesem feldweg
fährt ein mann der nur in latzhose
bekleidet ist keine ahnung warum ach ja
und er ist tätowiert klassischer
deutscher bauer würde ich sagen
[Musik]
der klassiker der klassiker man kennt
jeder der ein bauer in seinem
freundeskreis hat weiß dass die
prinzipiell keine t-shirts oder hemden
tragen wir irgendwas immer nur in
latzhosen alle sind natürlich tätowiert
und durchtrainiert und holen dann mit
ihrem traktor bis 1950 irgendwelchen
paris hilton lookalikes mitten auf dem
feld habe einfach so auf marke
[Musik]
sie sagt das so als würdest was geiles
hätte er zwei wollte mir allen ernstes
erzählen dass eine frau die so barbie
mäßig aufgebrezelt erst dann von einem
nicht bekleideten bauern auf dem traktor
abgeholt wird und sich darüber freut
dass er nach kuhstall riecht möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen das
gehört sich so mein neues parfüm ein
neues papier mit kuhstall
na ja und er wird sicher die nicht durch
das mal sagen würde aber dieses video
ist wirklich bauer sucht frau für arme
[Musik]
so gemacht als hätten bauern einfach
keine autos die die die bank einen
normalen autos die fahren einfach immer
überall nur mit dem traktor hin wenn ihr
mal ins kino gehen und die nächste stadt
ich kenne keine normalen autos fahren
sehen die fahren ja nur traktor oder
mähdrescher stelle mir vor dass er
wirklich so und wird einfach so mit dem
mähdrescher in die stadt fahren und dann
merkt er so ich habe einfach ein zwölf
meter breites mähwerk vor mein ding ich
kann es jetzt bergauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es war einfach überhaupt keinen sinn ich
meine was hat sie auch so erwartet sie
siedelten bauern sie weiß natürlich dass
bauern nur traktoren fahren die dürfen
ja rein rechtlich gesehen keine autos
fahren ist er klar und dann packt sie
soll ihren kompletten kleiderschrank
inso 30 koffer ein
dann kommt die partie schnell die koffer
ein ach mist ist ja traktor der
kofferraum wächst gras verstecken
wir können die sachen einfach im hohen
gras verstecken der water fakt ist dass
nicht pokemon alter wo soll ich denn
wissen das nicht so
aber perfekt getarnt einfach grünes gras
und mittendrin einfach pinkes und
liedern im gepäck natürlich erstmal sohn
louis vuitton koffer auch noch mal dahin
gerät zu kanaren kostenrechnung
ich weiß nicht 2000 3000 euro wer sollte
es sehen im hohen gras so ein bullshit
man sieht ist so krass gebt euch mal
dass man sieht dieses gepäck so krass
und warum hat der kann die show dann so
viele fragen
dass der pfarrer der fall
gerade unter den landschafts autos der
ferrari unter den landschafts autos
gesprochen wie ein wahrer bauer per
sollten steht das schlimmste ist wie
einfach die schauspieler selbst so 0 von
ihrer rolle überzeugt sind so 0
die rad einfach ihre texte roter die
sind so kein bisschen überzeugt davon
was sie gerade machen im gegenteil ist
wirklich so als würde ich die ganze zeit
so denken was mache ich eigentlich warum
habe ich dafür angemeldet ist der
ferrari safari unter den landschafts
autos
ich habe ihn vor zwei wochen auf einer
party kennengelernt
das war einfach schicksal endlich mal
jemand der kein arschloch ist und jetzt
sehe ich ihn auf dem bauernhof das wird
bestimmt super romantisch die beiden
kennen sich seit zwei wochen
selbstverständlich nach zwei wochen also
ich mal zwei wochen ist er quasi eine
ewigkeit wenn man sich dann schon zwei
wochen kennt kann man auf jeden fall
schon mal zusammen ziehen wenn da dann
nach vier wochen noch nicht die ersten
kinder geboren sind frage ich mich
persönlich woran liegt
ja das wird ja das wird was bestimmt die
wird bestimmt tatkräftige unterstützung
auf diesem bauernhof leisten
da habe ich überhaupt keinen zweifel
brauchst nicht helfen das war nicht mit
meiner mutter schon jahrelang wie
betreiben letzte zusammen das gehört
sich so dazu führen bauen
eine bauernfamilie sehr überzeugt
gesprochen ja das ist so bei
bauernfamilien
ja ja ganz klassisch so passiert das hat
sich auf jedem bauernhof in deutschland
die inhaber vom bauernhof wecken sich
prinzipiell immer gegenseitig mit
kuhglocken sondern saß toni auf der a7
schon was war das für ein schlag
ja gut ich glaube ich muss mal ganz
dringend einen youtube-kanal löschen an
dieser stelle
man beachte auch das tattoo auf seinem
rücken kopfhörer und ein mikrofon auf
einem bauern leckere stiefel
also ich muss zugeben ich habe selbst
nicht auf dem bauernhof gewohnt aber ich
glaube nicht dass auf dem bauernhof
stiefel gegessen werden
die alte spinnt doch denn jetzt wirklich
dass ich mit auf dem ruf anpacke
doch gesagt ich muss nichts machen
na ja dass ich mir auch wieder das
klassische bauern outfit wenn man dann
morgens um halb 7 7 zur arbeit geht
passiert das bei der bäuerin natürlich
in der regel mit hotpants in die gerade
so über den super g und bauchfreie ist
natürlich auch ganz wichtig weil
belüftung wenn man die kühe merkt er
wird sich schon daran gewöhnen dass wir
uns im haus versteckt
danke für die informationen gemerkt auf
jeden fall schon leute das macht alles
sehr viel und sehr gut sind werden wir
kurz beim blick in die kommentare der wo
bin ich hier gelandet button ja denken
was das nicht alle freund hält schön
dich zu sehen
hey du stinkst total kufstein benutzten
bruder muss der ball ja wir jetzt
dringend aber wie immer durch die folgen
bisschen zu lange wie sich alles in
einem video anzuschauen deswegen
springen wir gerade mal richtung ende
naja okay ich habe jetzt ein bisschen
vorgespult auf einmal ein dirndl an team
eine schlafbrille mit leopardenmuster
auf was ist dahin zwischendrin passiert
[Musik]
sie stellt fest rtl 2 hat es tatsächlich
geschafft hdtv noch sozialer zu machen
100 aus dafür wie man darauf kommt keine
ahnung aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt auch
nicht was ich weiter noch ihr zu sagen
sollen ich hab hier drinnen noch eine
playlist mit all meinen hilfen ihr
actions und hier oben ein zufälliges
völlig vorgeschlagen video verlinkt bis
zum nächsten video und sagt mir den
kommentaren mal ob ihr so eine barbie
auf ihrem bauernhof lassen würde